-I want to talk about
certainly another thing,
give you a chance to clarify,
the Green New Deal.
-Yeah.
-One of the things we're even
hearing the president say
is that you would outlaw cows.
-Oh, yeah.
-Cows farting.
That's would be out -- children,
hamburgers, ice cream.
Any of that true at all?
-No. In fact, I think it is
interesting.
it's always good to see how
these narratives
are manipulated, because
they're trying to say
that the Green New Deal is about
what we have to give up,
what we have to cut back on,
when, in fact,
the Green New Deal itself
is a resolution
to be more expansive.
It is to be able to
generate more
and to make sure that we're
investing
in working-class Americans
so that we all can afford
to have more in life.
So an affordable apartment
isn't a dream,
but a norm and that healthcare
is a right, not a privilege.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And, honestly, the only reason
I think anyone would have
to cut back on ice cream is
if their doctor advised them to.
-Yeah. And sometimes
doctors will do that.
Also it should be pointed out,
though, there are some Democrats
who seem a little cautious
of how ambitious
the Green New Deal is.
How do you talk
to your colleagues
within your own party
to let them know
that this is the right path
to take?
And have you met with
a lot of interparty resistance?
-Yeah, well, I think one
of the things that's important
that doesn't get communicated
is that
our Green New Deal legislation
is not a bill.
It's a resolution.
So there's two different kinds
of legislation,
and what a resolution does
is that if we pass
the resolution in the House,
it doesn't go into the Senate,
and it doesn't go to
the president.
It is a House resolution.
It is a declaration.
It is an intentional
vision document.
And what it does is that it
puts forward the large scope,
the overall vision of what
we're trying to accomplish,
and to say, listen,
if we're going to make progress,
we need to declare
our North Star
and our North Star
is 100% renewable energy,
it's Medicare for all,
it's tuition-free
public colleges,
it's investing in technology
and renewable --
renewable resources
and electric vehicles.
And -- and as a result,
any legislation, any actual
bills that do follow from that
are pieces of that.
So you can have one bill
that just addresses, you know,
battery storage,
like Representative Takano
out in California.
You can have bills
that just address
infrastructure investment.
And, so,
all of those are pieces,
but the resolution
of the Green New Deal
is the vision of what we need to
accomplish in the next 10 years.
-It's really exciting.
And I hope people actually
look at what it says.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Another thing that I think
everyone is appreciating
about this new generation
of people that are in Congress
is that it strikes me
that people show up in Congress
and then people who've been
there longer said to them,
"Hey, this is how
it works here."
And it seems like a lot of you
are now doing us the service
of turning to us and going,
like,
"You guys won't believe
how it works here,"
and telling us as opposed to
just accepting these rules.
You posted this photo,
which was fascinating to me.
Explain what's going on here
real quick.
-So I was shocked at this photo.
What this photo represents
are folks
who are experiencing
homelessness
that have been paid by lobbyists
to wait outside
of committee rooms
so that lobbyists can be
the first
and oftentimes only seats
in a congressional hearing.
-They're basically holding
a place in line?
-Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm.
-And when you saw that,
this has been happening
for a very long time.
And I certainly never heard
of it,
and I appreciate you
putting it out on social media,
because I think
it's a helpful thing for us
to know exactly what's going on
in this hall of this building
that we're all chipping in for.
-And it's not to say
that these folks sitting down
are doing anything wrong.
But, you know,
Congressional hearings
are not a Beyoncé concert,
you know?
-Yeah.
-They're two different things.
And this is one way in which
money and politics
has really sunk so steep
to the fact that everyday people
can't even see their own elected
officials
because a lobbyist has paid
to get in there first.
-I want to point out
one more thing
on the Green New Deal before
we go because the president said
it was, like, a bad report.
-Yeah.
-It was a poorly written --
He did not buy the science
in it.
But it's very unfair
to say that about you.
You are a winner
of science awards.
Look at that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, I personally never
went past, like,
the papier-mââché volcano that my
dad definitely made and not me.
[ Laughter ]
But this was a passion of yours
when you were in high school,
right?
-Yeah, yeah,
science was my first passion.
And I pursued
the Intel science competition.
I studied microbiology
and the impacts of antioxidants
on model organisms
known as the C. elegans
which is of the nematode family.
-I think that's something
you have in common
with the president, because
I think he did that, too.
-Because he's a nematode?
-He's an antioxidant.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you so much for being
here. I really appreciate it.